marc bonjour veaux au poil voilà les
fêtes de noël qui approche il fait un
temps à manger la dinde aux marrons
oui c'est la fête oui c'est là leur part
le grand repas que vous allez nous
conseiller et c'est pas un dingue c'est
une donne
pourquoi parce que la donne dans ce cas
là les meilleurs que le mal à vous y
vino
mais je pense qu'on devrait faire le
menu parce que qu'est ce qu'on va manger
avant une dinde aux marrons c'est quand
même un plat consistant aux bleus mangé
quelques 8 quelques 8 portugaise où
quelques buts de baulon des villes de
belon
c'est très bon les portugaises bien
grâce aussi mais pourquoi pas aussi un
plat de moules en pleine bulle sauce
poulette sauter c'est la tradition les
huîtres les moules cda plus oui mais
disons que pour leur budget la moule est
quand même moins cher qu'un conduite
1,13 us travaux et puis derrière on va
pouvoir mettre une petite salade une
petite salle mélanger ou mettre un petit
peu de marche un peu de betteraves un
petit peu de noix une bonne salade
mélangée pour manger avec landon
c'est après six ans et puis je pense
qu'on va sauter le fromage à bonbons
desserts et oui le dessert ça peut être
une bûche glacée une nouvelle chasse est
à base de chocolat
et puis peut-être avec des oranges des
oranges touché à vif l'orangé le
chocolat est une chose qui se marie très
très bien reset réf qu'est ce qu'on boit
avec tout ça et bien je pense que c'est
quand même le jour de la fête c'est le
jour fêtes de noël c'est important on
peut boire une bonne bouteille de
champagne bien fraîche bien glacée avant
pendant après sa mort est au champagne
peut-être bien grand père qui va vouloir
à son petit coup de rouge mais on lui
donnera au lieu de leurs accords
marie-mai est merveilleux et surtout pas
bras bien on va on va dresser on va
dresser une table magnifique il faut lui
table avec peut-être des attributs de
noël les chandeliers des candélabres
il faut que ça soit une table de fête
oui c'est beabrandon on vous connaît
quand même obligé d'être au moins six
car déjà lors uniquement une coupe des
coupes des coupes et puis il faut qu on
nous conseille quand même qu'on a oui
vous les verts assez fin pour le
champagne parce que je pense que le
verre épais c'est moins gouttes
oui mais bien eu tellement de relations
pâle
il ya des verreries en france qui sont
merveilleux la meilleure table du monde
mais si on repassait la recette de
laudun donne alors nous on va on va on
va demander à une spécialiste de nous
conseiller pour faire notre on va les
voir la spécialiste à primrose bordier
elle est bien jolie cette table que vous
nous proposez
comment avez-vous réuni tous ses roses
alors c'est ces volontaires bien sûr
mais vous les avez peut-être
qu'est ce que c'est que tous ces petits
napperons oui je crois que l'on il faut
avoir un parti pris de couleurs et voir
ce qu'on a essayé de faire ce que j'ai
essayé de faire c'est de faire une table
avec des sets de table que nous avons
peint fait des petites fleurs qui vont
avec mais tous les roses vont bien
ensemble tous les jaunes vont bien
ensemble
les petites serviettes sont laissées à
l'état tous les salons de la maison sait
pas quoi en faire
alors on peut l'éteindre en rose dont on
peut les garder tel quel c'est très
romantique on a mis des petites fleurs
qu'on lâcherait seulement difficiel les
bougies sont crème ou y et ça c'est un
drap de lit la nappe elle-même et un
drap de lit à la nappe est un drame est
là là on est unique et wick et leurs
frais et offrons tout on a fait tout un
mélange de rose qui va avec l'éveil
l'exercice yale les assiettes sont deux
choses différentes
différent oui on peut assembler à ceux
plus la peine d'avoir non c'est beaucoup
moins traditionnel c'est le coup de
woods ou d'ailleurs au fond s'est aperçu
que par exemple quand on prenait des
assiettes en verre et qu'on les
superposer ont donné un volume de plus à
l'assiette ce qu'il faut c'est choisir
un thème de couleur est bien resté
dedans il faut surtout pas mélanger du
verre mélangez du noir non il si on
choisit rouges et roses les bleus les
verres correcteurs la gamme très
important très très bien et leur celle
ci haut mais celle ci les dents c'est
beaucoup plus classique alors là dans la
mesure où noël est une fête de famille
justement les gens aiment bien avoir et
puis ça dépend ce que les gens ont chez
eux on va pas leur demander tout
racheter par exemple on va pas leur
demander de racheter des verts s'ils ont
eux mêmes des verts très classique ça
peut être très beau nous errons lambon
vers pâques est ce que cet agrès où ils
ont pris à rideaux fort mais on peut
prendre là dessus dit on peut prendre
n'importe quoi que nous avons posée sur
un foulard genre provençal simplement
celui là était dans les roses ce qu'il
faut choisir ce sont en général des des
couleurs qui sont parce que
hanches parce que c'est plus joli si on
montre des si vous le mettez sur un bleu
marine c'est plus dur à trop de couleurs
vives niveau on a une idée il faut être
très doux très romantique
on a pris des airs classiques désert à
bordeaux des cadeaux de mariage sous sol
argenterie de famille
la serviette à damas et blanc la
vaisselle de famille tout ce qu'on peut
avoir deux traditionnels chez soi c'est
très bon c'est reposant
et on a fait exprès de ne pas mettre de
fleurs de mettre des objets tout ce
qu'on trouve en verre chez soi ou en
cristal on met tout sur la table
chez soi en italie en pauvre où ça très
joli il ya aussi une formule mais y'en a
tellement à la ses formidables atouts de
cette hétéroclite ça alors là c'est un
atout là c'est un souci que j'ai acheté
cette insuline indien et dans lequel
j'ai même pu faire de nappes parce qu'il
était très grande enfin ça dépend de la
taille de la table moi je vous montre
antilles et vous avez apporté avec des
serviettes que vous avez trouvé du même
bleu on en trouve si vous qu'on peut
choisir un tissu de la même couleur ça
existe et on se fait alors comment vous
faites vous l'aimez ou les piquets
exactement simplement là j'ai pris des
serviettes famille on les atteint en
bleu marine parce qu'on a la manie
teindre en ce moment alors j'ai pensé
que les places étaient un peu
traditionnelle et moi ce que je fais
pour moi c'est que je prends des
corbeille à pain on en trouve partout ça
vole rien parce que les gens ne le font
jamais et je m'en sers le plat mais deux
places en soins aux attention poursuit
là où il pense plus publier
régulièrement ça a été une surprise et
je vois tous les regards différents
on mélange tout ce qu'on a je crois que
c'est très agréable d'avoir chacun son
couteau dans la mesure où on n'a pas des
couteaux pareil au contraire c'est
beaucoup plus joli on peut considérer
que sont les couteaux de collectionneurs
oui chacun chacun la couleur femme à
tilleur c'est la même chose pour les
verts je trouve que dans le système si
vous voulez du un petit peu oriental un
peu indien est assez drôle d'avoir des
verts dépareillé la vaisselle
dépareillée disons que vannes 22 amis
vous tombe dessus à l'apprenti juge pour
mieux et je mange bien le parti de faire
le exprimé en disant je suis très fier
de voir parce que j'ai tout mis
dépareillé à je m'en cache sens ils sont
des rappels et à l'heure toujours
toujours on joue à quatre marielle
rapport de dons là aussi on tourne
autour du bleu marine on tourne autour
de ses couleurs la mesure tout mais pas
en rose et ça c'est très très sympa
qu'est-ce que vous employez tout ce que
vous trouvez ça valait bien donnez moi
un tissu et huayi table ça c'est un
tissu c'est une app un peu à dien
macramé bleus marc et une quelconque 1
on peut également tan n'importe quoi le
tableau si vous l'éteignez pour une
soirée vaut mieux ne pas fixer et après
vous leur l'avez vous le faites bouillir
et ça disparaît si vous voulez vraiment
le garder en bleu marine parce que vous
aimez ça il vaut mieux mettre la
politique fiction l'autre je pars tout
ça aussi vous prenez comme la nourrice
n'a pas de choix vous prenez votre de
sully n'importe quoi simplement vous le
ferez déployés après tout le vieux et le
plus pervers
ça c'est des serviettes que j'ai pris
dans des tissus persan alors à ce moment
avec un apu ni où il vaut mieux avoir
une infinie et vous pouvez avoir des
serviettes personne celle là est temps
que ton mais si vous voulez très très
riches vous la faites en soit la durée
on vous savez la vie sud thaïlandais on
en trouve aussi c'est très joli mais
chez vous on peut vous emmener les
servir
regardez bien vous y aura des
changements ont fait leur effet jolie
pochette et bien primrose bordier grâce
à vous nous n'avons plus problème vite
des invités
la quel âge vous savez ça ce sont les
dden de crémieu c'est à dire la dinde
avec le cou noir la donne et bien ça
c'est une donne qui est né au printemps
c'est-à-dire elle va avoir à peu près
doit avoir neuf à dix mois c'est à dire
cette jeune bande nous bien bien fait
alors c'est l'âge idéal
alors qu'est ce qu'il va nous falloir
une dinde donne une donne qui fait à peu
près 4 kg oui pour 6 oui mais il en
restera un peu froid pour le soir oui
très bien et donc on va pas faire comme
on fait d'habitude c'est à dire
d'habitude on fait toujours retire la
dinde
aujourd'hui on parle à faire rôtir est
fauché dans un consommé et dans un
consommé où il veille à bras de la queue
de boeuf un petit peu de co2 vaut
désignons des carottes du poireau du
céleri du sel ou du poivre et pour la
farce
on va prendre de la gorge de sport bien
sûr qu'on aurait pu avoir de la chair à
saucisse toute prête
mais je préfère qu'on fasse la farce du
moment qu'on a une machine archer alors
qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut de la gorge
de porc et du maire de port un petit peu
dollar on va mettre un oignon un petit
sale [ __ ] de bris un petit peu de pain
c'est à dire on va bien on va mettre à
peu près 300 g de gras 300 g de maigres
100 g de pain 100 g de lait un oignon
une échalote sel et poivre et on prendra
quelques épures de truffes pour donner
bon goût et n'est pas oublier un verre
d'armagnac parce que vous savez
l'armagnac dans une farce c'est très bon
jeu mais là est bien le larron va
nouvelles on valoir chez en même temps
mais on va d'abord procéder comme on dit
à l'habillage de la dinde c'est-à-dire
l'habillage laden on va là la nettoyer
et la vider alors là il ya quelques
petites formules pour bien faire une
bonne passe que vous savez dans les
cuisses de la dinde
c'est plein plein de nerfs par là j'ai
une petite formule pour enlever les
nerfs de la dinde vous allez voir c'est
très spécial alors vous prenez vous
pouvez faire faire sa part votre
volaille d1
vous prenez le dos d'un couteau et vous
couper comme ça
voilà donc vous avez cassé votre mère et
là vous faites la même chose alors dans
le temps nous en cuisine on prenait les
pics feu mais des pics fait maintenant
il y en a il ya plus de pixels vous
pouvez regarder cela sur la cuisinière
ya public est alors je vous fais voir
comment on s'y prend
j'ai trouvé un manche à balai et pour
enlever les nerfs on met le manche à
balai par terre on pose les deux pieds
dessus et on va tirer comme ça ça c'est
un travail d'homme pour un voile a
renvoyé tous les nerfs sont restés après
la pâte et vous avez une cuite
entièrement des merveilles alors
maintenant on va procéder au nettoyage
de la donne peut-être pour la fin alors
là on coupe les ailerons c'est un pur
sportif réparation alors là on va
nettoyer notre d'inde
alors les couper le cou voilà le coup le
coup le mettra dans le bouillon à la
poule à l'aise parce que vous mettez la
peau du cou et on va la bride et parce
qu'il faut nous rendre coup grande peau
voilà et on a coupé ici bon on va garder
tout pour mettre dans le bouillon et la
tête la tête prochaine ou d'inde
alors là il faut bien d'enlever le jabot
parce que bien souvent ils restent des
graines l'intérieur les graines de maïs
au général l'envoyé alors là on passe le
doigt ici mais enfin moi je pense qu'on
peut faire faire ça passe en volailles
et un enfant si on habite la campagne
alors là vous détacher bien les poumons
un bien détaché des poumons vous les
sortez
non on les sort par l'autre côté là
bien sûr on pourrait la vider
entièrement par là mais pour une
ménagère c'est trop compliqué
on l'a vite normalement partie du groupe
union voilà alors on fait une fente et
là on va sortir le gésier le foie le
fois qu'on va mettre dans la farce parce
que c'est important
alors attention ne pas crever le fiel
ceux ci on crève le fiel tout est amer
envoyez les tout mon tout est venu il
est le ciel dans le joueur voit non mais
bien de l'instant voilà le fiel vous le
faire voir la dame donne est prête vie
des produits d alors donc voilà le fier
loyer le fiel c'est très important de
l'enlever voilà et là vous prenez le
fiel d'une seule une seule fois et vous
couper un peu plus pour vraiment se
regrouper vous savez que dans le temps
le fiel servait en boucherie les
bouchers gardait toujours le fiel le
fiel des dve des veaux fou parce que je
fasse des remarques et je me bouche et
les plots ils sont extrêmement blanc et
passait le plot ancien officiel et le
fiel donnait la blancheur au plo de
boucher alors donc voilà nous avons une
autre fois sans la plus besoin ou
l'autre d'inde et maintenant on va faire
l'autre farce pour pouvoir farcir
bestioles alors remettre la machine en
route
alors je vous donner un conseil quand on
fait des farces
oui il vaut mieux ça les avants parce
que si on sale avant ça donne du corps à
la viande mais vous allez même avec le
la même avec le larminat très peu de là
on met à peu près 15 grammes par kilo de
sel
voilà celle à huy poivre beaucoup de
poivre du moulin toujours là et bien sûr
et plus compact je fait tremper un petit
peu un petit peu de pain de mie de pain
de campagne dans du lait
et maintenant on va passer les viandes
vous tenez le site pian et en me mettant
en route
voilà longtemps
pas cette fois
voilà
mais poussés
lavez le persil est rare à cette époque
un trouver du persil au mois de décembre
mais ce n'est pas facile c'est fini
alors l'oignon et l'oignon est toujours
une échalote ail plus efficiente
la voilà ça sent bon
le coloré et les armes le pain trempé
dans l'est allez voilà
bon
impeccable ça y est formidable voilà
voilà
alors là on a notre façon on est bien
d'accord 300 g de gras 300 g de maigres
100 g de pain le lait 1 oignon une
échalote ail persil du persil sel et
poivre et fléchir détruits et en veille
cassé 2e et le verre d'armagnac
voilà des oeufs entiers banquiers et
puis on va y mettre dedans
les et plus chaudes truc alors qu'on
vient robe on épluche la truffe
voyez-vous une truffe parce que le reste
de la troupe
on va s'en servir pour la truffe est un
petit peu sur la peau savez vous allez
c'est ce qu'on appelle chez nous 2 me
day
vous savez dans le temps dans une
recette comme ça on aurait pu mettre
jusqu'à 3 400 grammes de truffes
mais aujourd'hui sinon on va se
contenter y avait trop de trucs mais je
m'ennuyais
voilà vous fait cadeau détruit à bastia
ou fait cadeau de truffes et vous emmène
en haut mettez autant que devient alors
donc là et là dedans on va commencer à
remuer c'est à dire on va mélanger le gr
1 avec les truffes les os et donc
comment avoir une farce et puis je
connais une petite combine vous savez
c'était fois on apprend bien l'oeil les
oiseaux rendent moins de farce que
d'autres s'il vous reste un peu de farce
et bien vous voulez ça comme vous voulez
une terrine et vous puisé sa au
bain-marie donc vous aurez une terrine
qui sera mangé fera dès qu'ils sa très
bonne offre la vôtre farfouiller elle
commence déjà à être bien et onctueuse
des très jolies vous pouvez leur goûter
parce qu'une farce à ce but a cru un tas
points et là dedans ça qu'ils ont dans
la terrine la la farce entérine ob il
faut compter trois quarts d'heure et là
nous allons mettre nos mares ou alors il
mare ou bien sûr on peut avoir des
marrons frères les est plus dense avec
gemma rose connaît une formule
extraordinaire base espère nous maroc en
réserves et voulait fonder un petit peu
oui
et vous avez sur votre journaux de
l'huile chaude vous trempez vos marron
dans l'huile chaude
il se produit un phénomène
automatiquement les deux coqs s'en vont
et vous avez un marron admirablement
bien éplucher futur comme pour faire des
pommes frites
le fruit du hockey lah oui vous avez et
pas attention bien fendu le marron à
tous les marins font du loup les marrons
fendue et vous savez que pour fins de
marron et une formule l'avait autres
marron qui est comme sa boule rendez
vous avez là il ya un maire ou un rond
ou le faon des comme ça est le nerf et
ouvrir quand vous le tremper dans
l'huile autrui il est très chaude et
vous trempez vos marron dans l'huile
bouillante combien de temps rabat le
temps qu'ils éclatent les éclats et vous
sortez vous marron de la friture et vous
avez lé maroc surtout c'est plus du tout
près voulait passer sous l'eau
bouillante pour enlever l'huile et vous
pouvez utiliser vous marc ayrault bien
d'autres cette donc là on va mettre à
peu près 300 g de marrons qu'on va
mélanger voyez il faut beaucoup de
marrons hors du moment qu'on a mis
beaucoup de marron il faut beaucoup de
grands parce que le marron c'est un
produit sec et bien non non non pas de
bord une petite goutte d'huile d'olive
parce que vous allez voir à la fin du
moment qu'elle est bouilli lui de noirs
dans un peu d'huile de noix huile de
noix cesser trop fort ni dali appui
l'huile de noix ça donne ce petit goût
de noisette c'est merveilleux alors là
oui bien les marrons sont là maintenant
le passage délicat il arrive on va donc
farcir qu'on va d'abord truffé notre
d'un johnny alors là vous faites des
larmes vous faites catelan 4bet l'homme
de truffes pour la glisser sous la peau
ça c'est encore facultatif ainsi vous
glissez pas moi vous savez vous pouvez
mettre tout les toutes les truffes et
dans votre farce
ce sera pareil à la veillée pour glisser
sous la peau il faut détacher les
chaînes acer comme ça sur la cuisse la
même chose un allah vous glisser une
lame sur la cuisse 1 c'est fait 1 une
autre sur le sur le poitrail drass rien
sans grâce à rien de l'autre côté vous
faites la même chose
voyez les traitant d'un set d'un donne
là qu'on s'enlève parce que la donne on
aurait eu un vieux d'un là il y aurait
plus de risques que la poutre ans
l'aigle et 7 d'un donne on va la cuire à
peu près deux heures dans notre bouillon
parce que du moment qu'elle est farcie
c'est plus long mais le bouillon le fait
avec quad et bien le bouillon va le
faire avec la queue de boeuf avec la
queue de veau
on peut même le faire avec des poteaux
feu et maintenant on va se farcir notre
vin donne alors là on va le mettre là la
truffe menacée et là on va lui et on va
labourer vous on garde les marrons à oui
oui il faut pas tenter d'écraser et on
va bourrer la dinde de l'intérieur donc
vous avez vu j'ai bien salée c'est pas
la peine de ressembler on est sale
pallada non puisque la phase là c'est
bien salée alors on est bien d'accord il
faut beaucoup de grands dans les farces
voyez la wii dans la somme en fait un
petit peu trop mais enfin bah tant mieux
on va faire qu elle atterrit vous savez
dans la drôme
il se fait l'espèce de caillette on
appelle ça la caillette de chaboy le bio
c'est un petit peu une farce fine qui
est fait comme ça et vous savez les
marrons dans une terrine ça donne bon
google
et s'il vous reste des marrons vous
pouvez les mettre dans votre jus ou
dignement alors donc faute d'un vous
l'accompagnez de tous les marrons autour
on sait la d'elle entourée de marrons
auxerre à dinde entouré de marrons
ben voilà tous les marrons tout y est
vraiment il y a d'la voix là et on va
vous voulez que nous explique une
histoire qui est vrai wang on a créé
mieux quand on faisait la dame de noël
ont fait la dinde à peu près deux ou
trois jours avant les fêtes
c'est à dire qu'on l'a fait pas le jour
même à effacer la couture on la fait pas
le jour même la dinde et on fait la
dinde farcie comme ça avec beaucoup plus
de trucs c'est à dire 300 grammes de
truffes et deux jours avant noël on plie
la dinde dans un papier sulfurisé
une fois qu'elle est payée dans un
papier sulfurisé
on l'apli dans un sac de jute il faut
avoir un jardin l'histoire est très vrai
vous expliquer pourquoi on creuse un
trou dans la terre et on enterre la
demande pendant un jour à deux jours
dans son jardin qu'est ce qui se produit
samour tri et cher les terres sont
froides chez nous 1 c'est du côté de
crémieu pour elle et les terres sont
froides
ça fait un peu comme un frigo l'odeur de
la truffe remis en terre et truffes
fraîches parce que la truffe fraîche qui
se retrouve à la ja éléments et toute la
dinde est imprégnée de l'odeur de
truffes mais alors il faut bien faire
attention parce qu'une année il y avait
neigé est impossible de retrouver les
dames
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait maintenant on
y met un piquet et on sait à charpy
tient qu'à la langue mais il faut avoir
jardin clos parce que je vois pas aller
enterrer votre nano tuilerie alors
maintenant
non mais l'histoire est vraie maintenant
voyez-vous bruit des bosses dames ça
c'est important alors voulu relever les
cuisses ou la tourner doucement parce
que la peine de phalsbourg et de farce
la voilà bien la bride et là encore la
maternelle j'appelle ça bride et avec la
mais vous savez que intérêts la dinde
comme ça c'est formidable un tout
l'odeur de la truffe se dégage dans
l'animal et après alors le jour de noël
vous l'a déterré et vous l'enlevez bien
sûr elle a été ça va on va la cool on va
la cour d'un petit peu tout de suite
parce qu'elle est donc normalement à une
fois qu'elle ait pas de bruit des bombes
à la cool un petit peu la couture moi ça
me connaît acheter lisez tout la cuisine
la voile alors les faire une petite
couture l'aller là et donc on va la
pocher on a un grand faitout un
pot-au-feu et d'autres avantages de pau
shenzhen c'est qu'on n'a pas besoin de
la surveiller risque au four qu'est ce
que c'est pénible
il faut l'arroser il faut voir des fous
rires là jamais un fou assez grand on
n'a jamais une plaque assez grande
j'ai vu des gens qu'il faut qu'il
l'emmène chez le boulanger le boulanger
il a autre chose à faire le jour de noël
qui s'en occupe pas l époque cuite et
lait cru tandis que la en l'approchant
un quart d'heure par libre vous êtes sûr
d'avoir une dinde est impeccable
voilà vous la tâche et oui voilà mes
attachées bon va la plonger dans le
bouillon on va commencer à éplucher les
deux carottes la voilà bon alors je mets
cuir de dans le bouillon avant la queue
de boeuf voilà oui oui alors le coup la
queue de boeuf la queue de veau vous
savez vous pouvez voir un morceau de
pot-au-feu 1
c'est aussi bien même je trouve la queue
de boeuf ça donne des bons bouillon ça
donne de très très bon bouillon et
l'appareil vous allez ça l'est toujours
salle et au sel gros à peu près à 10
grammes au litre voilà tout marche bien
et à ce moment là vous allez toucher
votre dinde dedans et on met là d'un
approché garde un quart d'heure par
lille et de nom email la garniture à
pot-au-feu
le bouquet garni avec un peu de laurier
un peu de thym 1 oignon les poireaux les
poireaux le céleri la tête d'ail et
quelques la robe délicat rock bien sûr
j'allais carole et lune et on va les
couper voilà combien j 3 oui ton métro 4
vous savez c'est bon les légumes
et puis vous savez vous avez tous les
légumes du pot-au-feu un saut plus elle
a fini on peut mettre un navet on peut
mettre alors je suis pas bien partisans
du ch ou plus voilà et vous savez
maintenant on va faire une petite sauce
pour manger avec cette main donne ah bon
on va faire une petite source à l'huile
de noix c'est à dire une fois que c'est
dingue dong est bouilli ont l'art osera
d'huile de noix c'est à dire c'est avec
un repas très très léger alors
maintenant voyez y en a pour deux or
pendant ce temps on va faire notre sauce
avec l'huile de noix avec l'huile de
noix et puis on va en chercher un petit
peu ce père si on valoir chez
grossièrement un parce que le persil
haché fin c'est pas bon ces infections
ah oui elle a aujourd'hui avec le froid
qui fait impossible de retrouver ni
sérieux ni rien du tout merci on va
arracher une échalote au maître d'armes
alors ça c'est une sauce à l'huile de
noix on va couper lannan bouillie et on
arrosera d'huile de noix pas la quitter
chercher on va mettre tout ça dans une
petite casserole
on va mettre du sel du poivre
chez nous il y en a des fois qu'ils
mettent un peu du miel de 20 ça fait
comme une petite vinaigrette on peut
mettre une petite goutte de vinaigre de
vin mais un jeu très bon jamais de
moutarde n'ont jamais le moutard les
labos on mélange de l'huile de noix dans
cette avec ses persie toussaint et
l'huile de noix donne un goût
merveilleux voilà bientôt deux heures
que notre ben dunn poche alors là c'est
bien d'accord on l'a bien écumé tous le
monde enfin enfin le principe d'un
pot-au-feu alors laden donne loi au
lourd passé loin d'être cuites par les
dons elle est belle oui c'est goûter
voilà alors on va masse et légumes au
tour 1 c'est lourd ça va un jour après
jour at il est là le des carottes
alors bien sûr
[Musique]
alors on peut on peut mettre les la
queue de boeuf on peut tout le maître
avec mais enfin je pense elle que de
beauf tout ça c'était pour faire le
bouillon il vaut mieux garder pour une
autre fois alors on va poser notre d'un
donne sur la table à l'envoyer les
cuites là on va là débridé c'est à dire
vous avez vu on avait là nos lampes de
truffes ont valade est ficelé oui on
peut on peut le rocher dans la sauce
voilà donc vous avez votre dinde nous
faut enlever la ficelle qu'on ait mis
derrière on va trouver une assiette
voilà alors pour découper votre dan
c'est très facile vous vous équipez
votre dinde en tranches fines mon amant
il ya les truffes leurs plats gardé un
goût mais voulait que vous continuez
découpé comme ça et à chaque convive
vous donnez une cuillère de farce
c'est à l'intérieur voilà vous avez
votre farce qui est à l'intérieur
voiliers qui est bourré de marrons oui
m'enfin ça va voilà vous bourrez votre
face ou mettez à face à clamart ouvriers
sont bons l'armagnac
ah oui l'armagnac c'est très très bon
vous voyez on retrouve les truffes on
retrouve tous et puis de ça vous pouvez
la rose et d'un tout petit peu d'huile
de attendez je les poupées matrouh où la
rosée d'un petit peu de persil de
cerfeuil d'huile de droit voilà et puis
vous pouvez humain c'est un peu la
truffe c'est nous pas comme on dit en
ardèche à lyon rend peu de tout
[Musique]